(soft music)
- Miscarriage, also commonly
called spontaneous abortion,
is the loss of a pregnancy
before 20 weeks of gestation.
So around five months.
Miscarriage is more common
than most people realize
and is influenced
strongly by a woman's age.
Women younger than 30
have a miscarriage rate
of approximately 17%,
and this rate doubles
by the time they are 40.
The further along a
pregnancy has developed,
the less likely a miscarriage is to occur.
There are many different
causes of miscarriage.
About half of miscarriages are
caused by abnormal genetics,
such as the pregnancy having too many
or too few chromosomes.
Other causes include maternal diseases,
trauma, and infection.
But, sadly, the reason
for most miscarriages
is never diagnosed.
Signs and symptoms of a miscarriage are
vaginal spotting or
bleeding, uterine cramping,
passage of clots with or without tissue.
The tissue may look like pieces of liver
or may be part of a larger blood clot.
If you think you are
experiencing a miscarriage,
it's important to call your provider.
If you have very heavy bleeding,
such as filling a sanitary pad
in the course of an hour that's sustained
or if you have severe abdominal pain,
you should go to your
closest emergency room
for urgent evaluation.
Some ways to help reduce your
risk of a miscarriage are
avoiding all alcohol, smoking,
and drug use during pregnancy.
Not drinking more than 200
micrograms of caffeine a day.
That's the equivalent of about
one 12 ounce cup of coffee.
Avoiding unpasteurized cheeses
or unwashed fruits and vegetables
as this could result
in listeria infection.
Checking with your physician
before taking any medications,
even ones you can buy
without a prescription,
as some may increase the
risk for miscarriage.
Many women who suffer a miscarriage wonder
if there's anything they
could have done differently.
I reassure my patients that
the vast majority of the time,
there was nothing that could
have prevented the loss.
After a miscarriage,
many women subsequently
have a healthy, normal pregnancy.
(soft music)